dans ce bar tabac il représente une part
non négligeable des ventes
les jeux de grattage et de paris
sportifs notamment pendant l'euro les
ventes se multiplient avec l'espoir côté
client de remporter le pactole mais pour
d'autres le plaisir de jouer peut
parfois devenir une véritable drogue
or l'argent fut plus que d'autres un peu
plus de moyens que d'autres mais en
personne qui dépensent l'addiction jeu
est aujourd'hui mieux prise en charge
d'autant que le phénomène serait à la
hausse avec le développement des jeux en
ligne une consultation spécifique est
désormais ouverte ici à tour sur le site
de port bretagne souvenir que je vous
lis ficultés au quotidien depuis le mois
de janvier 15 à 20 patiente était prise
en charge par le service majorité
d'hommes avec davantage d des jeux
autour du pari sportif et pmu les femmes
on les retrouve davantage sur du
grattage 0 5% de la population seraient
concernées par cette addictions
comportementales soit trois cent mille
personnes estimées à travers la france
13000 à l'échelle régionale et même
quatre fois plus si l'on intègre les
joueurs qui ont des risques de
développer une addiction fait on peut
caractériser la présence d'une d'une
addiction par le fait qu' il ya d'abord
une souffrance et la deuxième chose
c'est associé à ses souffrances une
perte de contrôle une grande difficulté
à pouvoir contrôler le comportement
l'addiction jeu une maladie au même
titre que les dépendances à la drogue ou
à l'alcool avec des conséquences
sérieuses sur le plan personnel et
médical stress dépression isolement mais
aussi dette séparation conflits
conjugaux souvent les proches ne
comprennent pas cette pathologie
il ya un petit système dans le haut
niveau cérébral qui s'appelle le système
qui gère la récompense qui s'occupe du
du plaisir finalement et qui nous
permettent d'aller vers tout ce qui est
agréable sur le plan biologique
il va y avoir des modifications sur le
plan cérébral qui vont faire que les
gens vont avoir ses envies très forte de
jouer ses envies répressibles et que ça
va être malgré eux et malgré leur
volonté psychologique
malgré leurs souhaits
vouloir contrôler la situation la prise
en charge des patients peut aller de
quelques mois plusieurs années
accompagnement psychothérapie traitement
psychiatrique pour les cas les plus
graves
c'est aussi sur le quotidien du patient
qu'il faut agir
on se rend compte aussi que les gens qui
jouent qui vont au pmu c'est qu'elle
sait aussi un endroit un lieu de
socialisation où et quand on enlève ça
et là y'a pus il ya plus rien il ya un
grand vide
d'où l'intérêt d'essayer de retrouver
des activités qu'ils ont pu avoir par le
passé consultations sont gratuites
financées principalement par un
prélèvement sur les recettes de ces
fameux jeu